because all i know are you i mean you're
excited to be here
but i don't think you're as excited as
you were the last time you were here no
that's true it's good to be back in this
where i had the greatest night of my
life
wow last time i was here i met rihanna
and i was very very
very excited i actually blacked out i
don't even remember the experience at
all coming on here on the sofa
meeting her in front of other people i
just remember like launching myself
across
the bottom garter to touch rihanna just
not even thinking about how that would
look
then i watched it back and i was so
embarrassed but we're we're not in the
same
way i can't even reach you
don't try don't try no it's yeah but i
know because often people say oh i'm
such a fan of someone who's on the show
and they come on go hi
no proper fan not just a foot telly this
is them backstage they'll go happy
ollie is oh look at that
he's like exploding out his face
back when people just stood right next
to each other i know
that time it's like they're married yeah
was she was she lovely she was she was
so nice and i gave her the album after
the show i was like you can throw this
you can put this straight in the bin if
you want to and she looked at me and she
was like
i would never do that and she hugged me
and it was the best it was the best
experience ever she smelled amazing
oh she didn't put it in the bin she just
left it in the dressing room
she looks careful she's asking people to
put things in the bin for her
could you thanks that's why i'm happy